احلى صباح صباح العربيه هكذا بدانا في اول
صباح من صباح العربيه كان ذلك قبل 18 سنه
وفي العيد العشرين العربيه نعود بصوره
الصباح الاول انا وانت يا محمد ابو عبيد
هيا ماذا فعلا انا وانت ماذا سيار اهلا
وسهلا بك معنا شاركنا في لحظه تاريخيه هي
لحظه ولاده برنامج نظنه حقيقه اكبر
البرامج الاخباريه الصباحيه في العالم
العربي والبرنامج الذي يجعل منا معا نحن
وانتم مشاهدينا عائله واحده
من البدايه هو حتى النهايه وحتى اليوم
شعله البرنامج مشتعله وتحملها الان نادين
خماش وسهام بن زموش هل تفضل
اسعد الله صباحكم مشاهدينا في برنامج صباح
العربيه هذه المره في عيدها العشرين نادين
يسعد صباحك سهام واهلا بمشاهدي صباح
العربيه وبمشاهدي قناه العربيه في هذا
اليوم الاحتفالي الخاص معكم اليوم حلقه
مميزه اليوم اهلا بكم
يسعد صباحكم نحنا فرحانين فيكم وبنكبر
فيكم فخورين فيكم حبيبتي واحنا فخورين
نكون معكم اليوم ونكون واقفين بعد هذا
الوقت الطويل انا بعدت ولكن كتير مبسوطه
بعودتي اليوم واحتفالي معكم والحديث تتمه
دائما معنا في هذه التغطيه تتغير الوجوه
تتغير البصمات تتغير الاساليب وتتغير
الابتسامات لكن العربيه تبقى واحده
العربيه لا تتغير هي بيتنا وصباح العربيه
عائلتنا ومن غادروا لا يرحلون وفي يوم
العيد يعودوا كانوا من وجوه صباح العربيه
التي عرفتوها تركوا بصمه كبيره وارتبط
صباح العربيه بهم وارتبطوا بصباح العربيه
نرحب ايضا بعادل عيدان راوي العلمي وماهير
عبد العزيز ودينا سالم اهلا بكم جميعا يا
اهلا وسهلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احلى لصباح العربيه وايضا كل التحيه
لزملائنا الاخرين ايضا الذين شاركوا
وتشاركوا في تقديم صباح العربي
عاده
والناس داخله طالعه وعلى فكره بدي اقول
انه انا اول موجز اخباري عملته من 12 سنه
كان صباح العربيه مع محمد وراويه
[ضحك]